after spiez be happy any purchase of a
tractor times sunday times for
education the banner
thank you hello to each and every one
of you i am we are happy
to see you again at the end of this
long morning of work with dominique
abel his team
we have done again this week
as we will do regularly
the point of the discussions led by
our technical
teams what have we done this week
ladies and gentlemen first of all we have
worked together on the framework of our
future relationship by discussing in
particular  of an extremely serious
and major subject which is that of the security
of the citizens of the stability of our
continent on internal security
we are ready to build an
ambitious partnership with the United Kingdom, which
in a few months will become
a third country as it wishes  and which will remain as
it has
decided outside of schengen in accordance with the
guidelines of the european council
this partnership would consist of q  four
pillars of effective exchange
of information first support
law enforcement cooperation judicial cooperation in
criminal matters and an
ambitious partnership to jointly combat
money laundering and terrorist financing
the kingdom's white paper  united contains
I want to repeat positive guarantees
on the protection of fundamental rights
and recognition of the role of the court
of justice of the european union as the
ultimate arbiter of
european union law but we still have to
discuss now on the
concrete translation  of these guarantees
subject to full reciprocity
and guarantees on the procedural rights
of suspects we now have
we now have, ladies and gentlemen,
the elements to build a
close and effective relationship between the
european union and the united kingdom on
several subjects which  are very
important for the citizens of the
framed mechanisms of extradition a
reciprocal cooperation on
air passenger data to better trace
identify individuals involved
in acts of terrorism
and finally change them to data
on DNA, fingerprints and
vehicles
we also have with dominique on board
obviously the questions of
foreign policy security  foreign affairs and
defense
there is also a broad convergence of
views on the ambition that we want to
have together in our future
cooperation and on the tools
needed to put this cooperation in place
finally, in this context of the security chapter,
we also talked about  of galileo i
simply want to repeat that the
european union offered the united kingdom
close cooperation
months ago i would remind you that the
signal for civil and commercial use of
galileo will obviously remain accessible to
the united kingdom and its companies within the
framework of  our new partnership our
offer also includes access to the so-called public
prs signal  ique regulates and and services on
the basis of an agreement which will be negotiated
with the United Kingdom as is the
case at the moment with other
allies
I am thinking of the United States or Norway
it is now in  united kingdom to
decide whether it wishes, as
we hope, this close cooperation
ladies and gentlemen on all
subjects of future cooperation
trade edc specific operations
internal security external security
foreign policy defense
our objective is to build  with the
united kingdom an unprecedented partnership
as i have said on several occasions
for several months is like jelly
recalled the day before yesterday in berlin the second
subject of our work throughout
this morning was obviously to
deal with and move forward  on the
outstanding issues in the withdrawal agreement
itself and precondition for any future
cooperation
some important points of this
withdrawal agreement which still remain to be resolved
on the  geographical
indications 3000 geographical indications in the 28
countries of the union
i have expressed my concern again the
position of the european union is
clear
the principle must not cannot
lead to a loss of
existing intellectual property rights we
must  protect the entire stock
of geographical indications protection
from elsewhere and
international obligations and since this is one
of the subjects of the separation it must
obviously be clarified in the
withdrawal agreement we will therefore come back to this
subject on which we  have to find a
solution in the withdrawal agreement other
subject of the separation protection of
personal data which will
be transmitted to the united kingdom until
the end of the transition, for example
by banks, insurance companies
or by  police forces on this
subject, which is also important for
citizens and for the sector
of the security economy,
we do dominique
think we can  tell him real and
good progress all the other subjects of
the euratom separation procedure of
the union governance of the agreement will be
the subject of new discussions in
the coming weeks
finally the g gentlemen reminder
on ireland and the  northern ireland
we must have a
detailed and operational back stop solution
legally operational in the
withdrawal agreement british prime minister
theresa may has committed to this point
as indeed have
committed to it all the leaders and the
institutions I think of the parliament of
the European union there is an urgent need to
work on the text of an operational stop tank
and for this I have asked
admitted that its team provide us with
the data necessary for the
technical work which we  we need
now on the nature the place the
modalities of the controls that will be
necessary this bac stop is critical
to conclude these negotiations since
I already had it ten years ago bac
stop  okay ladies and gentlemen
our work continues it will continue
intensely and I'll give you an appointment
next week we play this weekend
in belgrade
continuing in israel of mass crimes
like mba thanks to households to postpone
indefinitely the sharp drops for  the wine
and the negotiations
and helping to start and paul zeitz
believe his origins and his friends
charlottetown
but we hear well finding france
is a question we hear well in that
the atmosphere let's say the atmosphere and the
will
and great and you say with  emphasis
one opposite which obviously must please on the
side of Mr rap that the deal the
partnership that you will build in
the future on a partnership of a
new kind never seen before and that's
all that we understand that it  there is
will etc but on the exit agreement
you repeated what we have been hearing
for a long time, that is to say that on
the geographical indications on the ferry
stop for northern ireland
there is  more work to do
very simple question
can you give us some
elements that indicate progress that
progress has been made today or
last week where are we quite
simply where you are
still at  at the same point on these last
these last major obstacles cdéné
major chapter of the exit agreement
thank you first we do not
opposite i said about these words that
i used again yesterday or before-  yesterday
at parship tea press berlin the
truth when we examine the
relations that we have established for
20 30 or 40 years with several third countries
what we propose what the
european union heads of state of government
proposed in particular the canadians of the
month of March
if we realize it will consist of an
unprecedented
free trade agreement partnership in very ambitious
specific agreements in many
areas of common interest such
as aviation or transport or
cooperation  university
research material
everything I said about the progress
we are making because if you read
clearly we took the time to read
what I said earlier
in detail we achieve internal security
protection of citizens
it secretes outside we
are nurturing what will be in
time the declaration of the
european union and the united kingdom to
describe the
scoop of this future relationship
again there is no example if we
succeed in this  if they feed for that
there is no example of such a
partnership with any third country
the prerequisite as I huttler is
that we organize an orderly exit
from the united kingdom what is the condition for
building this partnership  unprecedented
and again being careful with the
words we use you can see
that week after week dad we are
eliminating topics that
have been agreed upon
if you look at what I said or
read what I  said  today, for
example, on the question of data,
data exchanges,
we have made progress on auratum, there has
obviously been progress, the focus
is more and more on the remaining subjects,
to be completely clear, the
major subjects which remain of divergences
and on the geographical indications which
are important not only for the
twenty-seven but also for many
producers in the united kingdom on
governance with the role of a tale of
justice and then on the question
of ireland obviously which is a point
j  i said crucial to get an agreement
here so we are working
i indicated the prospect of
very specific work we want to do on
the checks we need
for a ferry stop in northern
ireland and ireland who commits or when  this fund
is that we will find the work we
do and this after technique which requires a
lot of time and precision
ecclestone the cam is immersed web
dassault negotiates with  sometimes
when people tell me are you
optimistic
dominique said he was not
optimistic how pessimistic you are depending on
the moment there are reasons to be
optimistic or pessimistic when you
ask this question to the founding fathers  of
the european union you will no doubt be
sensitive to this reference jean monnet
are you pessimistic or
optimistic sumo is he answered
neither one nor the other i am determined so
i am determined i have been saying them since
the beginning has found an agreement for an
orderly withdrawal which is much better
than a disorderly withdrawal and we think
dominique and I that it is possible
to reach this agreement in October
even if the time is very short it is
not  a question of a few days or
even a few weeks but we
always have this objective
it is really fascinating this info
[Music]
no I did not say a word madam
2 of your last point no more
today than yesterday I  am not going  s
commenting on political life
in the uk futures the conferences of this or
that party frankly we are negotiating
with the government of theresa may with
tammy crabe and his team
they are the ones at the
negotiating table phoenix quarter and 9 to 12
hours of phoenix 106 song snippets
in november
2010 first we work i work
for a deal is again it
should be very complex very precise
since we are building to deal
i.e. a document which must be
legally precise and sound  and give
all the guarantees to all the
stakeholders and all the citizens
tell you the song next radio
the need the need for now we are
working to reach the
final objective of this agreement in the month of October
but it is not  not a question of a
few weeks I always said
that in front of you a few days a
few weeks so if we
need a little more time we
will have us  have that flexibility
the one thing i've said here before i
think that's also true on the
uk side
is if you take into account the
uk release date 29th march 2019
which is  moreover, enshrined in
British legislation now and
we are counting down the time
required for ratification on
average three months on both sides we are
arriving in November and at the latest we
have for this first stage of this
long negotiation and which
includes others since after this first
stage
its ratification hard to one or more
parallel discussions then plus one or
more parallel negotiations on the
future relationship during the time of the
transition for this first stage
we have the objective of  finish in due
time before november today
yes